i just found this link i'm going to send
it to tyler to pull it up very
interesting so this guy's apparently a
rapper is what he is uh yeah so he's a
rapper in 2020 he did a song
uh about chappelle
and he also said trump is my president
leave him alone in a rap song so pull up
the link so i'm actually curious now
did you see chris rock right there walk
up on stage yeah look at that yeah chris
rock sick was that weird
listen chris that's like a perfect
opportunity for him to get up there but
just so you guys know all of these
events that chris rock is at it's
preparing them to get a 100 million
dollar netflix special in the next few
months and i'm promising you they're
working on something right now go ahead
you were gonna say something no this
guy's 23 years old
um
so he's only been born and raised on
social media right since going up since
uh
social media has been what really ten
years strong maybe a little bit longer
with facebook but i'm talking like the
instagrams of the world 10 years strong
so that's all he's ever known but matt
you touched on something the blurred
lines between
it used to be a very clear distinction
between that as a celebrity they're on
stage that is who we watch and i'm just
a regular old person watching now i
don't know you touched on because it's
covid lockdowns homes on your phone like
all these blurred lines of like yeah i
could just i could just roll up on mike
tyson talk [ __ ] right i could just run
up on stage with dave chappelle i'm a
rapper i've got a social media i'm a
person i'm famous i'm famous too it's
like buddy there are clear distinctions
between a mike tyson and a dave
chappelle and your clown ass well the
difference between these two things
tyson in this case i mean this guy
attacked him with a knife this is
obviously some kind of
you know
beef the guy had with chappelle and he
wanted to you know
stick him but it's more of a mentality
this was a fake knife was it this is no
it was it was it was a fake
gun with a knife within it something
like that yeah so if you look at the
picture right there that's lapd hq and
the rest has been an incident where
comedian was attacked while on the media
was attacked
not they're not even naming the comedian
and the comedian was attacked while on
stage at hollywood bowl isaiah lee was
charged with assault with a deadly
weapon and bayless said 30 000 so if you
go a little lower
and
you'll see what he says if you go a
little lower that's the clip go below
the video and it says no uh i think
above that yeah go above that above that
right there so a little higher little
high okay least song
that is specifically titled dave
chappelle was released in 2020. it's on
that song where lee raps laugh at you
as a joke
and then lee has another song defending
former president donald trump with lyric
included mega my
n-word uh an open-ended question why is
everybody always hating on my president
interesting
and then
so and then joy behar if you go a little
lower said joe behar and sunny host them
blame trump for dave chappelle getting
attacked on stage which is obviously
it's of course trump's fault right they
claim he got into the minds of the
entire population didn't happen before
behar insisted santiago but i think
trump unleashed some incivility in our
country there you have it
um
by the way do you think this is going to
become a movement and more of this
stuff's going to happen like do you
think somebody's looking out there
saying this is a playbook i'm going to
do this as well
100 i mean
and i'm going to the like look i've been
pretty clear i didn't think that the the
what the will smith slap represented was
way worse than the actual slap a man
slapped another man chris rock took it
like a g
said all right i'll leave jada's okay
cool
um but just imagine
if this guy who actually brought a knife
on stage legitimately stabbed dave
chappelle and dave chappelle was in the
hospital now because dave chappelle is
very quick to joke hey thanks we got
jamie foxx here with a cowboy hat
everyone needs a jamie imagine if dave
chapelle was in the hospital right now
the overall sentiment in the country
would be like holy [ __ ] you brought up
the will smith thing right
that's obviously what came to came to
mind a person rushed the stage and and
attacked a
comedian or a celebrity or an icon but
imagine if chappelle is actually in the
hospital now or god forbid imagine if he
died what would the mood of the entire
country be would everyone be on pause
and be like what the hell is happening
right now guys what is happening right
now no thank god dave chappelle is okay
but this guy had a legitimate knife
imagine if it was a gun right and he
just boom shot him and that's how dave
chappelle went out it's a very very
scary situation yeah so a couple of
things goes i think about number one how
the hell
did that guy get in there with the gun
and the knife that's number one so
security is one to blame what kind of
security do you have with all these
celebrities being there like what are
you thinking with security that's the
most accountability yeah so number one
accountability to me is who put this
thing together who was your security
let's hold the security accountable on
how they got in what was the
infrastructure for somebody like that to
get in number two you know how in oh uh
911 happened tsa comes right after 9 11.
in november we have tsa right two months
after 9 11 we have tsa back in the days
you can just go hey hey mom she comes
out of the gate and you see her at the
gate people would forget that that you
could literally go to someone's gate
just greet them afterwards 20 years ago
my grandma would come and meet me off
the plane when i was a kid 12 years old
and that event like this changes so
you're you got a good point there now
think about it this way how much
different would this experience be
if
uh talent now said you know how back in
the days van halen would say here's how
we'll do it this is what we want in our
contract if you don't have this we won't
show up and they used to say they had
this thing with the m ms that they
wanted specific types of m ms and
multiple times if you didn't follow the
contract to the t they would leave
because they said you didn't follow our
contract and you're still liable to pay
us so they had a contract now imagine if
comedians say hey i won't perform until
you put a fence up or you put something
up that i feel safer imagine we get to
that point okay now if a comedian asks
for that say first comedian asked for
that that's what i want to do i don't
feel safe the craziness that's going on
here's what i expect
then that creates a trend so that
becomes the next tsa of what happened
after 9 11. thank god nothing happened
here but you have the guy that pulls up
to tyson you have the guy that pulls up
to him you have the guy that's
an fyi
dave chappelle has a crew around him and
they destroyed him that guy's lucky he
wasn't beat to death he's lucky he's not
beat to that but there's a part there's
a part that's actually good that that
happened to set the tone for everybody
else however how many people have
chappelle's size of entourage not many
nobody there's a younger comedian that's
getting up so you know how you go to
comedy and some guy takes a shot at
she's like oh
who are you you look like your middle
eastern let me guess you have a 750 bmw
parked outside right and you have a lot
of money odds are that car is stolen
papa these comedians say these types of
jokes yeah and i was like you know what
if will's me up i'm gonna get up and
then i'm gonna go out and so then this
younger comedian that's coming up it's
like dude i'm just
role playing with the guests that are
here now he gets something happening to
him so he doesn't have that kind of
protection he doesn't have a big enter
she's coming up so bigger guy may be
protected but the younger guy coming up
may not be protected so the games change
a little bit i'm very curious you know
what these bigger comedy clubs are going
to do to make their comedians feel safe
but i i would make the argument that
somebody that's not as big as chappelle
doesn't have a reason to be gone after
like the younger guy who's just coming
up i mean if you listen i think this is
a one-off people want to go after
chappelle because he's a lightning rod
right he's always in the news if you're
a young comedian and you're going to
this guy's show you're not going to beat
him up you're going there to laugh you
know what i mean i hope you're right
and yes i don't necessarily disagree
with what adam's saying but i think
there's so much to be said for what you
said pat that that this guy got the snot
beat out of him yeah like he's lucky he
wasn't beaten well listen that's what
happens in life sometimes yeah if if
people see this and they think about
going up on stage and then they look at
this guy i think they're going to think
twice but i also think that my mind's
going someplace else with this
it's making it about yourself when it
has nothing to do with you this reminds
me of like the streakers who come on uh
run on the field during the super bowl
or during uh the world cup
uh this guy you know steve will do it or
whatever the uh what the elk boys or
whatever they did it wasn't that guy who
did the super bowl thing one of those
guys but you're making it about yourself
you know that there's a lot of eyes on
you
drawing attention you're saying this is
my time i have an opportunity to get my
name in the news i have an opportunity
to put myself into the atmosphere that
all the eyeballs are looking at me and
you're making it about yourself it's ego
driven and the lines are blurred because
you're you have a public profile now
that's a whole nother thing don't get me
started on when you go onto someone's
instagram profile and it's public figure
yeah it's like buddy like unless you're
a famous actor famous politician you are
not a public figure i'm sorry but this
mentality this is my biggest concern
this mentality that like i deserve the
eyeballs dude dave chappelle deserves
the eyeballs he's the greatest comedian
living right now in my opinion been
going on for a while okay so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]